to welcome everybody to the only show in
town many people have said the greatest
podcast that's ever been made the
greatest show maybe possibly ever that's
been made the h3 podcast nowhere else
can you find this report of the
beautiful lovely he'll climb my co-host
some say the hole
some say I'm saying her I'm her go coast
you also have backstage ghost host ghost
we've also got backstage the one and
only Ian the intern the immortal intern
he's got he all the girls want him he's
a bachelor
what was that that was too fast Ian the
[ __ ] me we got Ian uh okay didn't we
figure it out so you could switch and
turn it on and off your Mikey and so
these are you have no excuses that is
correct
okay so Zack I'm done with you Zack my
sweet sweet Zack ah sweet young Zack our
sound loud a wee lad green but gold as
they say and of course the grizzled old
crusty excited but I was just saying
that he's the experienced he's whoa he's
experienced he's been around the block
he's not seen it and done it all we've
got Dan honestly now today's episode is
sponsored by me undies and audible me
undies and audible beautiful we love our
sponsors we cherish them we hold them to
be dear and I would never speak across
with any of them I will never speak any
ill will any of our sponsors for any
reason I'm glad that you clarified that
why would I bow or wondering I love our
sponsors every single one of them I'm so
exhausted I'm delirious you may know
this is a weird opening we went to
Disney yesterday which was a lot of fun
we brought the whole gang with us
we brought Danny and Zach and then all
of our Teddy fresh team there's ten of
us in total and
you know I think we're just all so over
it cuz it's not you want we did for nine
hours we walked I think we did twenty
thousand steps my phone said yes but I
don't know why then there was like fires
in LA when we got home we had like a
babysitter who was with Theodore and she
had to leave abruptly because she
thought her family was burning alive at
1:30 and I'm like so tired I just got a
shower about to go to bed he's gone
excuse me excuse me mr. mr. Klein my
family nobody answer and my whole family
and I drive home okay
she's rocking back and forth I was like
stuck with the baby 1:30 a.m. I've got
work today
oh yeah yeah anyway and that Zach got
evacuated pours poor sweet Zach I mean
how was Jack tell me about that it was
gnarly expand we know well I was like
dead-ass tired from Disneyland like all
of us and my brother comes with my room
around 1:30 and he's act we gotta get
the hell out of here oh man so it was
look like a war zone by my house and you
could see the fire from your house
totally a hundred percent war zone
sirens how far was the fire from your
house at the time I would say wait what
dad what did you just say Zach we're
talking about the fire it's very scary
your house is close to the fire it was
about a two miles away at the time two
miles away it was yeah it was oh you
went to bed the fire wasn't close you
woke up yeah hell yeah
beyond Hell beyond help you
everyone was getting out of deep hell
the neighborhood
deep deep hell I went from the happiest
place on my nose funny we were driving
home from Disney on the five and the
fire was like right at our ass because
we got home and then when we got home
apparently the five was shut down so
something we were [ __ ] bounced out of
there so quickly left Sparks and I saw
Dan throw cigarette butt out the window
and it was kind of coincidental that the
fire started right as Dan threw
cigarette butts because we were speeding
like a madman cutting across the freeway
no that's true I did do that yeah we had
a moment where we had a moment in the
car but we made it a moment we did we
survived everyone survived Zach you're
fat you have family and your house is
everything's fine barely huh barely
what do you mean barely just I'm
exhausted okay the house wasn't there
was no and no no no thank God but it did
there's like a bunch of stuff everywhere
well I'm thank the gods that you're fine
our nanny is fine her family's fine
everybody's fine except the people of
course they lost their house but I don't
know any of them everyone's fine that I
know that's all ours so we have got
first of all we've got a lot of big
stories here
oh yeah yeah Disney was fun oh I do have
some actually some interesting reports
from Disney space melon rolls we did
Space Mountain did we do these VIP tours
this is Kimberly our tour guide she's
awesome we do these VIP tours where we
get to cut the front of the line and
it's like it's so sick
anyway week and you can stay on the ride
and do it twice - I don't know if I
talked about this last year but it's
like class warfare is crazy like there's
all these little kids in line who have
been waiting two hours and you just you
walk by them and you look them dead in
the eye and you say if your parents had
more money
you wouldn't be in that line and you
spit in their face you say peasant [ __ ]
you kick him
you get allowed to get one child in line
at Disney if you have a VIP tour right
either no this was Guardian to the
galaxy's well I mean what was your
guys's experience because I've done the
VIP but you you have to do the VIP tour
because obviously there's a lot of
cannot exactly going incognito I mean
we're all red beating it out so we get
some we're getting stopped a lot which
is very nice and I cherish all my fans
all the fans that come and say hi it's
very sweet and beautiful I I even
invited people to come say hi to us so
I'm not good I like it it's great but
it's it's sometimes you sometimes you
need a chaperone because it can get a
little wild and it ends up being like a
fan meetup right people start queuing up
as Duff can someone say something about
Disney Dan had a interesting experience
right this picture on cars was moments
before it this ride is not extreme like
anyway so dance understand famous last
images I was screaming like a madman all
day Dan pute and [ __ ] yeah after cars
and I got so we're getting off cars and
he puts his head in the trashcan and he
yaks and I'm like oh damn is dad okay
and I go back there dude that smell was
crazy bro
good good it was intact I mean the cars
ride was obviously what put it over the
top but it was the it was the roller
coaster right before the cars ride that
kind of [ __ ] me up we did it twice and
then frankly I'm going twice isn't that
cool it all it kind of ruins the ride
yeah yeah it's not as exciting you know
and then you definitely get motion
sickness it's kind of pointless in
Cairo's it yeah
[Laughter]
this is a good one I was trying to look
cool and not scared didn't work I was
trying to look badass and you yakked in
the trash can I say Kimberly our VR tour
guide she's been doing this for decades
she's a seasoned pro I says Kimberly how
many times has someone pubes on rise I
mean Dan just puked and on the cars ride
of all things which is like a kids ride
and she goes well the only ever time
someone's puked is a child who was sick
so Dan you were the first adult in her
decades of experience that puked on ours
ride no Ian was a joy lil Ian was
laughing yeah Ian did you have anything
you wanted to add oh it was the best
part is beautiful what what was so
joyful about it for you I mean just that
ride specifically I don't know how Dan
drives a car do you get nauseous when
you drive to work that was Ian's joke
other highlights include Zac skipping a
bunch of rides and people calling him a
[ __ ]
Zac was scared of a bunch of rides I was
like dude what's right did he skip or
you're like you're such a [ __ ] you know
Splash Mountain what the roller coaster
which was the best ride you know it's
okay you know it's messed up though cuz
you did the crazy ferris wheel and that
one is like so much worse than all the
rides you skip scared the [ __ ] out of it
yeah I had to pop in like my headphones
to get through it like yeah you had the
Dingle music I need to design out it was
so scary yeah he also it was where Ian
skipped we did a Peter Pan and
Fantasyland
which is for like one year olds and Sark
was like super scared and didn't want to
go on it
so I don't know you bitched out a lot of
rides but it's fine we had fun
Ian in DMP all day hmm
he was making a point of it you know
it's funny a lot of people coming up to
us we kept going to Ian so are you do
you have to pee or what and I was like
what there was one of the people you
know when you get off the rides and he
pointed Ian he's you know for people
with small bladders yeah I love that and
then I learned something about Ian that
really I mean you guys know that we've
been doing this bachelor anyway I gotta
focus on talking I'm so exact is a
terrible episode I'm just exhausted you
liked this show and you just like
watching a sit here that's fine but
don't expect anything of value to come
here this episode
Ian we have this show The Bachelor
we they're three with the age three or
your capital H and a three very clever
and we've been setting up him with all
these dates and I'm learning now and
he's a girl he hit him up in the
Instagram DMS and she wanted to join but
she missed the cutoff and now they're
getting somewhat serious and I'm like
okay well then we got to bring her in as
a wild-card and Ian goes I don't want to
include her in the show and I'm like
okay Ian then let's do it my way because
he goes she's outside the show I says
Ian you found her
from the show she wanted to be a
contestant you're ruining the integrity
of The Bachelor this is serious we're
here to find love in and you found a
girl outside of the game show format and
you're Rafi engine I says okay well then
Ian why don't you just tell her that I
want her on the show and let her decide
and Ian says no I'm like all right then
dude love is it my hands
and I'm taking the power back because
the show is we have out of people that
would love to be the bachelor Ethan
Ethan yeah I know you are agreeing but
do you see we have people requesting to
become the next Bachelor and we have
some really eligible people lined up
okay now you for you to I mean what's
going on here you and can you say
something and what do you think the
other two are gonna think no the two
girl he's so bad exactly speak for
yourself
go ahead I don't remember signing
something where I had to pass over every
diem to you guys for review beforehand I
don't remember that no we well I don't
remember that either because it doesn't
happen but what I do expect is that if
we're doing a dating show for you II
they did they will correct me if I'm
wrong because you guys are a big
bachelor bachelor nation yeah yeah
didn't the winner like he wasn't
invested all and he did it just to boost
his music career Judd yes that is true
but so the actual bachelor has no
integrity to it
well Judd wait so okay okay his name is
actually Jed but we like to call him
John so John got slammed about his who's
fake intentions and also having a
girlfriend outside of the show so if you
wish to be treated like John careful
because people take it very seriously I
think a lot of people will take it very
soon it's true I don't expect you to
tell me every diem and corresponding you
have obviously although I would
appreciate I would like that to be
honest but okay I don't expect it
because obviously you have a private
life that being said she did come to you
in association with The Bachelor dating
show is that correct yes or no the three
was around that time yeah and she did
she did she or did she not say that she
wished she was in the show and she
missed the cutoff she mentioned the show
yes okay and do you think that
having an outside influence like this is
jeopardizing the integrity of the two
finale do two finalists that we've
selected I don't think so
okay why how okay but hold on let me ask
you this then Ian wait okay
how often do you talk to cuz you were
texting with her all the time we were at
Disney yes or no not the whole time no
you texted with her a little bit while
we're at Disney have you spoken to any
of the other two finalists uh one of
them okay how much have you spoken not
that much now do you think it's fair to
the girl you haven't spoken to it all
and and then meanwhile you're texting
the other girl while we're at Disney I
mean my dm's are there they're open but
you deemed they're open you're saying
but she's what she won't I think that
she's you know has more integrity she's
yes although I to be fair I never said
don't DM yeah that's not a rule yeah but
it it could be assumed it's that's a
rule yeah all right
100 percent if anything I think
messaging him is kind of like well
someone really competitive maybe would
do that it's a slight cheating yes but
it's like a gray area it is a gray area
but someone who would win The Bachelor
would probably go the extra on that
extra step towards connecting with the
the contestant but my point is is I am i
fitting this whole thing has been
jeopardized because Ian seems to have
real affections for this third girl and
I'm sorry if I'm out then what's the
point exactly
oh what's the point if she's if we don't
get to talk to her ian is it
embarrassing you that I said that you
have real sections for the third girl
you don't know what's going on there's a
reason why because because well your
main why are you not on camera why are
you showing me when I talk to you I
don't understand your main goal is to
make this as critical a goal
love for defying you love what is your
plan for my next assignment well we have
okay the idea for the finale is that the
two finalists call in on a skype tablet
we're gonna set up a nice dinner table
like Italian with the red and white
checkered fabric and a rose and some
wine and some spaghetti and meatballs
and I'll sit across from Ian holding the
tablet of the finale contestant and Ian
will have a one-on-one date with them
but I'll be holding the tablet yeah then
we'll be recording I don't know do you
have a better idea
that yes we need to know entertaining
and why I may know is that gonna play
live music mm-hmm danken is that can you
play like flamenco hell yes
let me it goes like the Spanish with the
nylon yes it's a romantic hell yes
okay in yes why would anyone not want to
be a part of that a proxy date with
Ethan walls Zack plays I got a date with
me somebody's got a hold the tablet
that's a good point
I don't know a robot over the tablet so
what you want to you guys when you know
how when you learn to drive the driver
next to you can take over at any point
learner driver yes then needs to have an
override there switcher so that when Ian
talks then can switch onto him I agree
it's outrageous that you don't show you
when you talk I mean it's upsetting to
me and we went to great lengths in to
get you a button to us to get you the
mic to open and here you are still
dodging it I'm doing it I'm pressing
buttons I'm all over I got this it's a
lot to juggle to be fair to be fair to
you then is it is it possible to have a
second switch we'll see what we can do
it is possible actually I'm gonna have
to do that
the only thing is basically yet we just
need you dance who switched in and yeah
yep
just like the master you actually do no
way to do that well anyway that's
something I learned at Disney - we're
still on Disney and I'm I just I don't
know what to say because Ian it's a lot
of drama I don't know what I don't know
how much integrity the show has left so
what do you I'm worried these girls are
gonna pull out now because I just I
scheduled the whole thing with them for
next week like it's all they're gonna
see this episode because why would they
not want to be in if I'm giving you two
finalists and they're putting their
heart on the line for you and you're
gonna have to pick a winner no you need
to disclose first of all that you are
interested in a third girl at all
let alone the fact that she's interested
in being a contestant on this show if
you really love her in you will let her
compete so you can pick her everything
you say only makes me realize I should
never shouldn't have even mentioned this
[Laughter]
we'll find that's that's the wrong
attitude that's the wrong thing all
right well let's move on because I don't
think we're getting anywhere here but
but do you see my problem at least you
see the conundrum that I'm in yes so
what do you want it you're extending the
invite to do a wildcard yes or what well
I didn't want to even have this
conversation like this to be honored but
you didn't you didn't leave me any
choice I gave you all I give you
reasonable options and you you reject
all of them I said I wanted to introduce
her as a third wildcard but but I had to
reach out you said reasonable options
I'm pretty sure that was the only option
no I said I said well at least what I
said to you that I thought was
reasonable at least tell her I want her
to be on the show and give her the
option okay well now she's aware
[Laughter]
there you go okay all right well this
should accomplish she local is she local
no where does she live
okay maybe let's let's cool it there but
what's her dress yeah but we have to
read non-local girls then right that's
kind of an issue although that's what
the bachelors do they're like I'm
unemployed in Los Angeles and I just
fell in love with another unemployed
person from Kansas I love that show
ian is employed though so let's move on
well you know so that's that so Disney
was fine we're all exhausted ela was a
champ she wrote everything she looked
good doing it too I'm not I used to be
more scared I don't know what happened
you did you did it I mean you did it all
I dragged her ass to Disneyland a lot of
times now kiss and yesterday was our
tenth anniversary seventh anniversary so
congratulations to us on seven years of
happy domestic bliss lots of patience
and prayer I wish we had a sound byte
which is an idiot with the sign he
didn't say it um I want to talk about
the Gatsby crash Bobby Lee was our last
guest and we loved Bobby Lee and kalila
they're awesome funny Craig Gass was a
fantastic episode you guys may add those
who didn't see it pretty sure we pulled
the video he's over here those who
didn't see it should wash I thought I
pulled this well man I wonder why I want
to show the clip of him crashing and in
short he took the Gatsby with kalila and
you know we always do this I had a
feeling that someone was gonna do this
he's like floored it and crashed into
the wall and I'm and I suspected he did
it on purpose because Bobby's a little
while
a little crazy and he's always trying to
get a laugh but um well let me show you
the clip for those of you who didn't so
without for those who did you're gonna
like it anyway they're do Bobby and
kalila please enter yeah right now rips
hard and he just totally missed the
missed the entrance for the entire frame
of the door Oh our office is like a war
zone now from the Gatsby what is the
condition of the Gatsby now it's also in
pretty good shape it's just it's got one
minor issue that the acceleration gets
stuck the cellar ation and break
actually the break is just reverse crazy
so it's very unsafe to do but I think we
can fix it as my point it's probably
fixable if we have a good gatsby
mechanic so if any of you guys out there
are a disability mobility at the
Commission's we would like to invite you
here you know I think a good handyman
could could fix it up but I was actually
quite concerned about Bobby his foot was
Sam I'm showing here his foot was
sandwiched between the metal and the
doorframe and I was actually I was
laughing uncontrollably because it was
just so ridiculous but I was actually
quite worried I was trying to pry his
foot out and I couldn't stop laughing
but I was actually quite worried
yeah and he's everyone he's totally fine
but what shocked me even more is that I
went I saw them their new podcast title
was called I survived we survived h3 and
I was like oh they talking about us and
then he goes on to admit that he crashed
on purpose let me play this rich
rational
you guys I suspect that I need to fast
to furious what were you thinking Bobby
what what was going through your mind if
I would have gone through the doorway
clean right yeah I would have taken out
either Ethan right no no I couldn't get
along well he was going back everyone I
kind of like [ __ ] hard dude my leg got
twisted in a bunch of metal you could
know for real if you had you knew that
you were going to do this yes because I
wish I would have been warned there is
no prepared preparation plan to crash
that [ __ ] scooter falls feet into the
wall I had a feeling that some it was
gonna happen eventually dan we need
protocols now we need safety protocols
I'm just happy no one was hurt I me too
i I
I was trying every buddy can attest
backstage I tried multiple times to get
him to chill out I was like you don't
need to be this far back you don't need
to go fast it's thin paper you'll just
just like a few feet back and just no no
man
and yeah that would be really bad he
goes on though to describe his the ones
who get hurt more are the ones who tense
up that's what I'm saying
before impact and the ones who survived
better are the ones who are asleep in
the car Tony Ferguson absorbs punches he
gets punches but he gets punched the
reason why he doesn't get hurt is
because this would they say the
commentary my friend Joe Rogan and my
other friend Michael visiting my friend
Dominick Cruz never met him what about
John annek never met him anyhoo here did
your friends any hole yeah yeah that's
right he knew who I have know what I'm
saying now let's watch them they're
better just be like yeah I'm like just
watch this today we're tired that's like
all right guys we're just watching movie
today
ah so fun we're just having if we get
hurt we don't have to do it if I hurt
myself enough I would have been like I
would even do something more more just
to pop it out or whatever I really was
trying to get out of that that was an
easy podcast those guys the nicest
people in the world
yeah podcast has been a real fun and as
of late and sorry to interrupt but we
have another yes I'm sorry that was a
weird I had this weird cut where there
like was that a homage to Dan no there
was no
I think they just had a hard cut anyway
he was purposely trying to crash to get
out of the interview mm-hmm I'm glad he
didn't hurt himself because I I feel
like you never really know what's the
truth wid Bobby I know I think he was
just trying to be violent ya know was he
could have pretended to have been hurt
that would solve a just so cuz we were
already recording anything I gotta go I
gotta turn the ACS house a [ __ ] is it
break time damn so sorry to interrupt we
gotta go to break
hey was that real I mean that was the
sound bite but yes okay so little break
because I gotta turn up the AC but after
this we're gonna get into the real
content enough with the BS okay because
after this we got the we got Bella Bella
Delfin our friend of the show found her
named Belle Delphine did I say correctly
Belle Delphine of course I know her name
she's a friend of the show she really is
she turns out it was arrested and
updates follow Thornton look I'm trying
to get people to stick around and watch
I mean let's put cheat I think what she
did we're gonna get into it but she
wasn't she posted at long last she
disappeared for a long time and she
posted what seems to be in reaction to
our latest podcast so that's fun I want
to talk about blizzard verse China
actually Hong Kong vs. China blizzard
being a little bitch-ass and bowing down
to China China and the NBA - of all
people bound down China outrageous I got
a lot to talk about
and of course we've got Ethan Bradberry
conspiracy theories will follow as well
so we've got a lot of good stuff on that
guys don't go anywhere we will be right
back after these short
commercial messages
it's spooky soft dealer it's me undies
it's soft like the best thing you've
ever put on your body soft its soft like
a fluffy kitten dressed up in a pop
pumpkin costume soft like softer than
the brains that zombies love to eat Oh
have I gone too far
well you get the idea these are the
softest undies known to man and they're
also available in sizes extra small -
wait for it
4x yeah I'm getting close to 4x Oh baby
I can probably fit into 4 XL and and be
comfortable
I'm serious to excel I'm losing space
and to excel people think I'm kidding
it's soft fur although if you're 5 XL
nobody's gonna cater to you you could
ever have to find a different underwear
supplier me undies look take a look at
these great prints you've got the spooky
spooky skulls the doughnuts I don't know
that those are Halloween themed but
they're very cool and they're certainly
soft as it gets me Andes has a great
offer for my listeners as well
if your first-time purchaser you get 15%
off you get free shipping and let me
tell you it's a no-brainer especially
because they have a hundred percent
satisfaction guaranteed that means that
if you don't if you're not 100%
satisfied these are the softest most
breathable incredible underwear that you
have ever felt grace your taint [ __ ]
dick impulse or vagina in the case of
women then you will get all of your
money back as a 100% satisfaction
guarantee right now 50% off first pair
free shipping 100% satisfaction
guaranteed go to Mia news calm slash h3
me Indies dot-com / H h3 problem
what an astonishing thing of book is
it's a flat object made from a tree with
flexible parts on which are imparted
lots of funny dark squiggles but one
glance at it and you're inside the mind
of another person maybe someone who's
been dead for thousands of years book is
proof ELA that humans are capable of
working magic who said that not Albert
Einstein Carl Sagan said that he said
that about books and I agree books are
the closest thing we have to magic but
we don't all have time to sit down and
read a book we sometimes are driving
exercising doing other things it's a
busy world that's the beauty of the
audiobook we can multitask and the magic
has become even more magical that's the
power of audible now audible has an
unmatched selection of audiobooks guys
the one that I'm gonna recommend to you
we're talking about China and how spooky
China is as a police state I don't know
if we've talked about it at this podcast
at this point the bug is or not but 1984
is a is a book that I read for the first
time recently that chilled me to the
bone it's a it's truly a horror story
really of the of the human mind and
spirit and um it's it's full of twists
and turns honestly that I didn't expect
that someone who's never read it and it
really I mean George Orwell when he
wrote this this guy had a third eye
because he saw he saw things that
shouldn't have been accessible to a
human being especially back then I
cannot recommend this enough China
scares the hell out of me you're gonna
see what I'm talking about when I
explain it and listen this book I think
it's fantastic it'll change your whole
Danu you add and it said that it
informed his whole life view this book
single-handedly 1984 I mean guys if you
weren't rich or so in spirit look no
further
audible members can get more than ever
before every month you could choose one
audio book regardless of price plus two
audio originals from a fresh selection
on top of audiobooks and audible
originals members get access to
exclusive guided fitness and meditation
program
just go to a UD IB le comm / h3 podcast
or text h3 podcast - 500 500 and browse
their unmatched selection of audio
content start listening with a 30-day
audible trial choose one audiobook and
two audible originals absolutely free
visit audible.com slash h3 podcast or
text h3 podcast - 500 and 500 welcome
back we were yelling all day yesterday
so all of our voices are like trashed we
all feel like we're getting sick new
scooter videos I forgot to mention let's
watch those obviously this was called
the double kill outside you can see a
what looks like a bodega you've got two
old ladies oh well let's do a
play-by-play let get start out or even
better ridiculousness
well let me pause that reverse it oh I
hate ridiculousness that show sucks
anyway I'm sure I'll be on it soon yeah
right you imagine they really only have
well there was some good ever yeah they
have everyone somehow I don't know how
they booked everybody I think like even
Obama was on ridiculousness
yeah it was crazy Hillary Clinton was on
there mom Paul was on there too that one
that didn't make sense from Paul but he
was on there shut up - Ian Gooch who
made this Facebook so anyway just got a
scooter pulled together
Ethan focus focus you folks are up
[ __ ] old Nana got Dumbo today yeah
but no seriously we do got her
play-by-play
you know all these club shows I like
tosh point-o for like a year it was good
[Music]
here we go guys we are going here we go
now you got an old guy here's a Nana she
gets tumbled right away and she I mean
that's a straight Nana she's like 82 so
she's a crazy I mean Frank she'll
probably never get up again and I'm not
trying to be funny but at that age you
don't fall gracefully now late to Nan's
and why do these dangerous I'm saying
and then he just pieces out he totally
just oh they're Nana's are both down for
the count do it all that remains it's
her purse that just lies quietly and and
finally truly a final resting place made
the black crazy I made a mobility
scooter now we've seen that uh you could
knows what's up though that was the
autoplay should I watch this again or no
I mean it's pretty wild like homie you
gotta be this is not toys I mean
especially not the Gaspee we think
they're serious machines they need to be
treated as such you can't just throw a
90 year old guy on a damn Gatsby and not
expect him to kill to Nana's that wanted
well whatever it's got like a hole on
the back he's got like a hold back
packing situation
this is very much intentional like the
first one what's happening I think no I
think he got confused and hits on
reversed and he can't stop other
delicious Malaysia that's like I mean
that's like murder oh no and the second
that porn the first one never had a
chance but the second one she's trying
to hobble away bless her soul but she's
just so old but this lady's like that
someone's carry my shouldn't be laughing
but well maybe shouldn't have kids the
targeted nobility people that's what I'm
saying though more outrageous look them
in the eye wow that's a creek oh he's
not wait he didn't look old he looks
kind of like more homeless than old like
get a look at his face he looks
middle-aged old guy he's younger than
they are for sure God wait maybe that is
malicious but cuz he looks like he's
like 40 or something you know that's
crazy
- he's got he's actually very mobile you
can that was like a really good 180
definitely a better turning radius on
that than me yeah that thing ATS six
wheels for like slick the god speeds
like 50 feet determine what you know
what he's not autoplay like YouTube give
me a break
I don't turn it on and I've turned it
off like a thousand times and that is
true um this guy knows what he's doing
because after he takes him both out look
at this he's like he's very in control
yeah turns on a dime out of there oh my
god that's horrifying if you actually
murdered those two Nan's
I don't think it was malicious then why
would he bounce that's the drunk driving
drunk driving activity if he was almost
drunk driving is it oh [ __ ] you could
probably get a DUI on one of those
imagine like you lose your license for
drunk driving and then you get a
mobility scooter and then you kill
people and your mobility scooter truck
driving anyway so we've given a lot of
mobility scooter people [ __ ] because
we've called them menace to society
we've called them a dater to our
children but what if I told you that
scooters could save our community you
know would you call me crazy or would
you call me a attention visionary crazy
well I'll let you judge there's some I
don't know what the context there's some
reporters and some immigrants start
getting violent
they come with masks and they start
getting violent and trying to get them
to leave
and some well here cheap slate
we've been individually attacked hunched
that producers being punched you've been
runner
drives his mobility Scott turns
intervenes attention turns intervenes
drives his mobility you know could be
used for good and evil is the tool this
is the tool like nuclear energy scooters
are a force for good or evil and
depending on who wields it and how it's
used
much like the powers of Superman hmm
screws don't kill people it's who's
driving right right we got to start off
this first scooter lobbying group like
that and the NRA this that the Scutari
don't kill people people do anyway
scooter us that was fun
blizzard boycott this thing is so stupid
blizzard first of all it's a video game
company as you all know much beloved to
all of us if you're around my age you
probably played Starcraft starcraft
brood war visionary life-changing game
Starcraft mm-hmm
you've got World of Warcraft you've got
Warcraft one two and three you've got
you know so many great games that
they've made the habló for Christ's sake
but they've they've more and more since
they got acquired by Activision who's
just one of the big evil behemoths of
gaming become just a really soulless
money machine World of Warcraft
obviously is there it's funny
Warcraft's their most famous game but
they were they were like you aren't
unanimously loved before that like
universally loved before world of
warcraft everyone was like they're the
pinnacle of great gaming and after world
war crafts they just got too much money
I don't know it's crazy but anyway as
most competitive gaming companies are
very popular in China a lot of money a
lot of people in China and there's some
riots going on some political strife
between Hong Kong and China want to read
what's written here for me at this point
which will be more clear for our
listeners and not just me rambling so
here been to read now in the wake of
about 18 weeks of ongoing protests in
Hong Kong several American businesses
have now become and broiled in a larger
issue of cowing what do we got here what
is kowtow to China's a thorough kowtow
cop tau Cobb tau e KO tao e to china's
authoritarian totally and dollar aryan
totalitarian government this is serious
cow talent being the world's most
populous area it actually is originated
from cantonese so the world most
populous country ultimately the next
global superpower well that's
editorialized damn well sure they're
number two but America's number one
forever okay but Blizzard during the
Asian Pacific hearthstone grandmaster
season 2 finale in Taipei capital of
Taiwan there was a player called Liz
Chung who published Chung blitz Chung
the pub he has publicly supported
solidarity for Hong Kong during a live
feed now this
the fallout of this clip which I'm about
to show you was catastrophic the Chinese
government does not tolerate any
criticism of the government doesn't tell
her any protests any dissent it's not
down at all and it will count like it
their reaction to this is over the top I
mean here is the here's what it was this
guy won a tournament
he's in like the calm calm right now
what happened was um he said something
in support of the protesters and
Twitter's ruining my life again but you
could see the the broadcaster's know
it's gonna be [ __ ] you're not dude
people are trying to know you can't say
[ __ ] about the government hmm it's crazy
different existence to what we're here
you know like I could call Trump a big
fat orange yeah baby and it's like yeah
everybody says that about him that's a
that's we got to appreciate how amazing
that is you can never do that before you
can never say the king was a [ __ ] you
get slain on the spot but we could say
that about our rulers and that's a
beautiful American thing and China is
[ __ ] scary so in response to that
they go
what he said was liberate Hong Kong
Revolution of our age popular slogan by
the Hong Kong protesters Blizzard has
since banned this player for one year
they revoked his winnings from that
tournament which in this case was
$10,000 and they are justifying it as a
breach of contract because they say
you're not allowed to make political
stance of any kind on a live feed the
incident has provoked rare bipartisan
condemnation with both Marco Rubio's
involved oh no
what did he have to say about it Marco
Rubio says recognize what's happening
here people who don't live in China must
either self-censor or face dismal
dismissal and suspension China using
access to market as a leverage to crush
free speech globally that's a very good
point actual actually Marco implication
this will be felt long after everyone in
US politics today is gone because this
happened in Taiwan and there Blizzard
from being pressured from China is
cracking down on on a Taiwanese player
if I'm understanding that correctly but
the effect so here's effective
immediately
bliss Chung is removed from Grand Master
and received no prizes additionally he
is ineligible to participate for 12
months hmm we will also cease working
with both casters really well then the
casters they're like just everybody's
screwed and by the way I this I'm a guy
who was involved in the competitive
Starcraft 2 scene like I was in very
deep I know how much love and hard work
and like dedication it takes to even get
at that casting booth and you're like
dude when you're investing your whole
time energy into something like
hearthstone of StarCraft it's like and
you get to that casting stage there's no
plan B you know what I'm saying I don't
know why they had to make an example of
the casters I guess because they weren't
like oh how dare you
mm-hm so crazy the only the only
rationale I think I've been able to
gather is that the casters couldn't like
they should have cut him off as soon as
they saw that he was wearing I agree I
mask yeah but yeah as soon as he was
like wearing stuff like that they I
guess should have known I mean obviously
they shouldn't have been fight he won
the damn tournament give the guy the
helmet oh [ __ ] they said we'd like to
reemphasize tournament and player
conduct within the hearthstone eSports
community from both players
and talent while we stand by one's right
to express individual thoughts and
opinions players and other participants
that elect to participate in our eSports
competitions must abide by official
competition rules
[Music]
yeah that's [ __ ] I don't think they
would give a single [ __ ] if like someone
was like [ __ ] Trump whatever so it turns
out the Chinese tech giant $0.10 owns a
5% stake in Blizzard and I guess the
reason is that the casters encouraged
him to stay
apparently they say in Mandarin say the
eight words and then we'll end the
interview immediately oh they encouraged
her they knew where had you read that
dad to know that and an article I'm just
reading now as we as we are so they
encouraged him to say it well that makes
sense then then they need to burn and uh
they need to be thrown in the in the
bottomless pit along with him Chinese
tech giant ten cent owns 5% stake and
Blizzard and in the second quarter of
2019 Blizzard earned one hundred and
seventy three million dollars from the
asia-pacific region about 12% of its 1.4
billion worldwide total revenues that's
a lot of cheddar two hundred million
dollars but I also think that they're
thinking like China is such an emerging
market dude they almost don't even care
about America anymore with China on the
rise like if you look at games like dota
and League of Legend they're it's all
Chinese players it's huge in China so
you know Blizzard has to it's like at
what point does the the need to make
money intersect with the Western ideals
that we that we hold so dear I mean it's
a really complicated topic it seems like
because I'm sure it's not that simple
but you know on one hand
like that's China and do you I mean
should we take a stand against it and
just not do any business with them right
well I what's the difference between
doing anyway I mean should it shouldn't
nobody here do any business with them
yeah I mean I I'm fairly ignorant so I
may be speaking out of turn but I mean
China scares the [ __ ] me because like
I'm reading about how they're rounding
up millions of migrant Muslims and
re-education camps like silently just
silently rounding up people and what
seems to be described as some like a
less extreme concentration camp but
something that could quickly turn into
one if you're rounding up a million
migrant Muslims and just to reeducate
them whatever that means and like the
[ __ ] that China's doing with the social
credit cards you know to get on a metro
now in China you have to scan your face
and then you have a social credit card
so if your rating goes low you can't do
you can't take public transportation you
can't leave the country they have
abilities to controlling their
individuals citizens so much and to
suppress dissent so much that that's why
it reminds me so much of 1984 because
never before have I ever thought that
what I read in that book was possible
the ability to squash the human spirit
as I see there in China
can you imagine you if you speak out
against the government
they ding your social card and then you
go in the subway and they scan your face
and you're like sorry [ __ ] you can't go
in the subway anymore
that's awful I mean dude that's like
crazy control so I don't know as a
Western world but there's emerging
superpower what kind of what does that
look like in 100 years I don't know
[Music]
but currently like everywhere every
almost everything is made in China like
everyone all over the world is working
with China yeah I think it's a I think
we are going to be confronted with the
horrible truth that we have created a
monster and you know it makes me think
world war red before World War 2 United
States was not the world superpower but
when Japan came and bombed Pearl Harbor
it was famously said that they had
awoken a sleeping giant and America
quickly became like a dominant world
power as a galvanized all of its
manufacturing power into like warfare
for World War two and they just end and
I think China is just silently gathering
so much wealth and resources and power
that if they become the predominant
superpower the landscape of the world
you know Western ideals freedom
individualism these truths we hold to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal and given with unalienable rights
by our Creator the right - yes
expression that's the Bill of Rights but
they say the pursuit of happiness
yeah life life and liberty I'm not sure
that the Chinese agree with that you
know they certainly don't agree with the
freedom of religion as religion is
outlawed completely in China or or
speech right if you can't speech a
speech free speech oh my god like what
they're the definition of they have
technologies to prevent free speech
that's what it is scan your face anyway
this is kind of a there's such sensible
[ __ ] though it's like dude well this
so this this example from the NBA is
even crazier this actually shocked the
hell I mean there's been a lot of
protests within blizzard by the way with
employees walking out there's been the
lead developer of a lot of their classic
games world Warcraft Diablo 2 StarCraft
brood war tweeted I'm done I made this
is
actually a great one Dan showed me this
and this guy made the game he says
please tell us more about why you're
canceling a roller Warcraft subscription
I made this game with the team
I'm applo I'm opposed to blizzards fear
of china and the silencing of blitz chun
i'm calling up blizzard to stand up for
what is right so there you go the actual
creator of the game is out but once
again it's blizzard blizzard is just so
behemoth now that guy he's like cool you
made the game 20 years ago thanks for
the money idiot that's what Mozart said
in response so here there's actually
more examples of let's see here they
hold up a free Hong Kong post right here
the suspense won't last any longer they
do draw the second time not for long
spirits WP
yeah they just cut away to just get off
of it baby
this NBA one is even crazier though I
didn't see this one what is this damn my
character
yeah they're doing all this stuff to try
and be a character and over watches
Chinese so they're trying to make her a
symbol of the Hong Kong movement was
pretty Hong Kong women to basically
punish blizzard by making that character
so associated with it that China just
bans the game of overwatch from pretty
clever that's that's pretty clever right
there they're trying to turn her into
like a that's pretty awesome actually
oh yeah the oh damn oh the chairman of
China they keep making fun of him that
he looks like Winnie the Pooh and
apparently it's it's a illegal to share
Winnie the Pooh memes in China mm-hmm
Chairman Mao wait that's not him no not
not no that's a different what's his
name is he an ex i Danis is simple last
name here
they say they make fun of him that he
looks like looks look at nice guys that
crazy he's like I just died like I like
I was so life insurance dude I'm like
the man at your local chase yeah well he
is uh not such a nice guy here's to
great individuals the two greats dude
you needed lighten up bro huh little you
little uh ciao uh uh I'm blanking on his
name Kim Kim little Kimmy little Kim
needs a life gym bro that haircut is so
outrageous it looks like me I'm at are
dude like nobody should ever have that
haircut that's straight out of [ __ ] my
[ __ ] up he is like a black dudes haircut
from like the 80s
it's got like a hip-hop haircut I don't
wanna anyway
chairman ye Winnie the Pooh this is
illegal in China so don't want you in
China otherwise you'll get one Winnie
the Pooh JH apparently tilden what what
could I find it dan what are you trying
to find the one in the Pooh meme where
his faces photoshopped his money the
Pooh well I mean
and you're looking at a bunch of them I
don't know what specific one you're
talking about
anyway apparently they been but yes yes
yeah they've made that image illegal
there don't [ __ ] with that this is
boring anyway there you go Winnie the
Pooh did I can beat off to this it's
free Hong Kong revolution out why she
like that like so there you go now this
NBA stuff I think really underscores how
crazy they are okay first of all the NBA
that's American as it gets all of this
stuff comes right at the heels of the
Blizzard controversy there's a team
called the Houston Rockets their general
manager daryl morey while in japan for
pre seeming preseason games on friday
expressed support for the ongoing
pro-democracy protests in Hong Kong
tweeted a photo that said fight for
freedom staying with Hong Kong here it
is okay general manager of a American
basketball they you know that's a fair
stance to make as an American we believe
in democracy and freedom so he quickly
deleted it the NBA has a lot of money in
China the Houston Rockets in particular
Yao Ming one of the most popular Chinese
basketball stars played on the Rockets
his tenure on the team helped make the
game so popular in China and cemented
the Rockets as a fan favorite in the
country of China team owner tilman
faretta for Teta tilman for dente'
quickly condemned it bitched out big
time he says just so you know listen
this guy does not speak for the team our
presence in tokyo is all about the
promotion of the NBA internationally and
we are not a political organization our
Andy anyway just seems like a minor like
a minor misunderstanding
then he quickly apologized the guy who
made the original tweet and deleted the
tweet and he said Joey the original tree
said Don 10 my teeth the cook I did not
intend for my tweet that caused any
offense to rocket fans and friends of
mine in China I was merely voicing one
thought based on one interpretation of
one complicated event I've had a lot of
opportunity since that's week to hear
and consider other perspectives it's
like whoa dude there's no mysterious
conversation some serious [ __ ] and the
back channels which you'll find out what
it was
I've always appreciated the significance
port our Chinese fans and sponsors have
provided money and I would hope that
those who are upset will know that
offending or misunderstanding them was
not my attention my tweets are my own in
no way represent the Roth it's just one
guy yeah manager who tweeted that he was
in support this tweet this is a great by
the way Tibet Hong Kong world and this
one I don't can't say it so I'm not
gonna lie even I tried it it's [ __ ]
yoghurt those are the Muslims that you
were talking about there here's what
happened ok the Chinese government cut
ties with the Houston Rockets as did
several other businesses including the
team's Chinese sponsors the government
said you're the whole team can you're
done in China
dossie the CBA along with $0.10 which
streams NBA games in China to almost 500
million viewers cut their ties you're
saying they cut ties with the entire NBA
I I'm not sure if it's the NBA or just
the Houston Rockets this was actually a
couple days ago so there's probably been
development since then let me look it up
oh yeah they're they're cutting ties
they and I know they pulled all the
merch from stores and don't like dude
this is like a huge industry because
this one random guy and they brought
it's actually Marco Rubio really
summarized it well he's like they're
bringing down the force of the whole
government against anyone dissenting
them
the guys are not Chinese he's thought
he's just an American basketball game
and they've brought the consequence of
even mentioning support for Hong Kong he
didn't even really should talk China
resulted in the the team being outcast
and the NBA losing its partnership with
the whole [ __ ] China so what's the
NBA gonna do now on top of this it's
reported that they are debating whether
or not to even to fire the guide oh just
because of that one tweet I don't
understand that's so crazy you have an
update was he fired
doesn't look like he's been fired yet
but I do I did just do an update CCTV
pulls NBA China games broadcast in
response to the atom solvers support for
the use in Rockets GM right to free
speech LA Lakers and Brooklyn Nets are
going to meet next week but for now
neither game will be screened so yeah I
mean like they pulled all the broadcasts
of NBA games out there popular team in
China yeah yeah cuz ya mean who's like
mega famous there cuz you have a really
great basketball player Chinese dude and
the Rockets were his team so yeah that's
just so great it's like that's
terrifying right I mean the yeah or
they're over reactor they come with such
and they move you neuralyzer like if the
whole government is like it's like if
YouTube boom works with China then we
can't say what we just said about them
potentially but I think YouTube and
Google already been banned in China but
I'm making a comparison yes to the
situation exactly if YouTube let's say
that's that's exactly comparable let's
say that's China becomes YouTube's
biggest market and they're making 50
percent of their money there and we're
here talking [ __ ] about China and the
government goes YouTube and says ban
them forever they can never stream on
your platform again mm-hmm and condemned
them publicly or you cannot do business
in our country yeah ever it's like
there's no free market there it's just
the government whatever they say goes
and so that's kind of what it's
happening here with this one [ __ ] guy
made one tweet now the NBA's [ __ ] over
in China and they're now the NBA needs
to like fire this guy yeah and to the
Emmys credit I mean you read the
statement where the owner of the Rockets
was kind of condemning it but Adam
Silver who is the Commissioner of the
NBA is backing up the original guy which
is why they're pulling off the
broadcasts so he's he's not he's been in
the knee did he say something publicly
about it yeah he's that he's the
president of the NBA the Commissioner
Commissioner I like that like Gordon but
in terms I can understand Dan he
supports the free speech rights of
Rockets GM Darryl whatever the [ __ ] that
guy's name Maury huh good for him so
that's what I'm saying
they're they're not backing down there
but their reaction is the opposite of
Blizzard's right mm-hmm lizard fired
everybody immediately and just said
sorry abyss China scared us from saying
if they're terrifying
that's just seem so insane that I from
over here will have to comply to their
nonsense the government yeah and so
we've put we've I mean we've put China
in this position where they have this
incredible leverage over everything
because we wanted access to all their
cheap goods and labor now they're strong
they got it all baby
Marco Rubio would have put a nice tweet
let's see what Senator Ron Wyden said
Blizzard shows it is willing to
humiliate itself to please the Chinese
Communist Party no American company
should censor calls for freedom to make
a quick buck
I fight yeah I mean it's easy to say but
I I think fundamentally I do agree that
as Americans look it's in the
Constitution it's in the very fabric of
being that defines who we are as a
country that we you know that we believe
in freedom of man and that we should
support the freedom of people overseas
like people in Hong Kong fighting for
democracy and free
the free the freedom of man benefits all
of us and until we're all like free in
that sense to say and believe what we
want then there will always be conflict
in the world I feel like you can I don't
know that that was the thing the central
theme of like 1984 was like can you ever
really silence the voice inside someone
I'd like to think that no all right but
that but yeah there's people working on
it
keep that voice quiet by not to not to
just dominate you physically but also
mentally mm-hmm anyway let's talk about
Bell the reason why you all click this
video that's right Bell Delphine
I love Bell I should give her equity in
the show at this point I get more views
it's great I love her she's the best
I feel like we have a symbiotic
relationship you know what I mean
I wish she would come on the show she
would be she would be the best guest
ever she's so secretive
we made a podcast called Belle Delphine
arrested by English authorities which
admittedly was an outrageous title but
it was fun and it got you all you idiots
to click it here you are again but it
was it was a joking reference to that
she had disappeared for months she had
just disappeared and I was genuinely
worried about someone that I that I've
that I care about and I don't mean that
in a weird way I mean like you know
she's a strong personality we have a
symbiotic relationship and I just wish
her well and I own some of her spit
instantly to it by the way
Ian's going to a pornhub Awards tonight
he's gonna wear the I on some bail
Delphine spit hat excited how you doing
on time and you okay I'm getting a
little closer but it'll be all right I
can still go
okay you want to take you want to take
over for him dance so we can go cuz I do
want that report I'm good for a little
longer
we got time okay yeah yeah okay good
yeah Ian's gonna go to the pornhub
Awards it's gonna be awesome I was
giving you [ __ ] earlier today but that's
so cool that you're doing that so thank
you you are appreciated and valued Ian
but we're gonna need to ruin your social
life as well I understand yeah Val so I
think she honestly must have she must be
trolling right like here she tweeted
this out right oh my god I can't show
this [ __ ] do you didn't show it did you
no okay good I just opened her banner
I'm like oh this is so pornographic huh
I'm trying to think how can i okay can I
just view the image directly yeah but
you could still see well they don't need
to cut to the screen until you're ready
you know okay so here I'll do it I'll do
you can like zoom in how do I show this
Dan cuz it's still great out like just
okay dad sent me the image directly ding
yeah thank you
she tweeted this image out like the day
after our podcasts says Metropolitan
Police and she's got runny mascara she's
smiling the tweet red I got arrested lol
I got arrested LOL she's at 200,000
likes holy smokes that's awesome
she's she's like anyway then she sent
another update Society she followed it
up by explaining she was arrested for
vandalizing someone's car for stealing
her hamster this also has imaged it red
what does STG swear to god oh i swear to
god this girl came to my party and stole
my hamster i have no idea why or who the
[ __ ] does that i spray-painted the [ __ ]
out of her car and got arrested at least
I got my hamster back [ __ ] so here I'm
gonna read so weird
oh [ __ ] can I show this he's a master
trawler
she really is dan can you download these
cuz I mean I can't show it
it's got titties everywhere oh wait no
no no I can you're gonna try it here
first and then yeah cut to it yeah look
it works alright but just be careful
because I'm gonna get [ __ ] if we show
some titties she said here's her text
messages said said you saw you carrying
my hamster outside but thought it was a
joke but now my hamster is missing so
where the [ __ ] is she have you taken her
hello can you reply please lo what are
you talking about I didn't take your
hamster outside
I literally have two people saying they
saw you lo ok then oh that's a [ __ ]
response did you take it or not not lo
ok then so what the [ __ ] is this then
hate it and then here's a screenshot
she's got receipts from the girl who who
ratted her out hey did you take Belle's
hamster the other night because she's
been asking lo yeah I thought it would
be jokes she got the receipts [ __ ] what
now that's so [ __ ] up why so then she
went to her car and did it pay pay me
and clown with a gun on it pay pay
yeah pay pay good art [ __ ] she's a good
artist - she's multi-talented I'm so
scared asking show titties ok
yeah there you go it says [ __ ] me my
hands they're back that's pretty awesome
and then she got the hamster back so
congratulations to her now go off the
screen because I am scared so apparently
she says I got arrested and she shows
the mug shot here now Dan had pointed
out there are conspiracy theories
stating that they believe this mug shot
is faked would you like to expand on
that down oh I mean I think it's pretty
definitive that it's fake ok I mean the
main thing is that it says Metropolitan
Police and people looked it up and the
mug shots from that police department
don't have that watermark so so you're
saying if she simply just didn't do this
watermark she wouldn't
I've given her yeah oh there's other
things I mean it's the fact that it it's
a little out of focus all of the mug
shots from that department are always
very sharp the backgrounds a little
different you know the four chance she's
drooling
she's drooling it's not I mean those
pictures of the car all spray-painted I
mean that's if she's making it all up
that's going pretty far for the joke I
mean kudos doing well the paint the PP
drawing was this looked like it was
washable p with the [ __ ] frog that
bakes PP the [ __ ] frog it looked like
that was washable paint but the spray
paint wasn't yeah I do think that Belle
would buy a used car or just do it on
she's so crazy I feel like she would
just do it on someone's car for the gag
no she went to no I don't think so but I
do think that she would go the extra I
do that's what I'm saying the extra step
to to create whatever she needs to
create for this job get the buzz and she
got the buzz the story went mega due to
viral here everyone couldn't debate I
got arrested law Belle Delphine post mug
shots
gamer girl Belle will says she was
arrested Bala Delfino claimed she was
arrested yeah maybe she oh that's me
what the [ __ ] that's me
h3 shares the craziest theory behind
bail Delphine's disappearance it was the
other thing everybody fell for the bait
of like they didn't I guess they didn't
actually watch it they just saw the
title they said there you're obviously
joking well I thought it was a pretty
good theory that she got in legal
trouble yeah I mean yeah respectively
obviously we're clearly speculating
right during the October 4 episodes h3
podcast hosted by h2 h3 ethan klein
the youtube comedian shared his crazy
theory about why bail teen has
disappeared from social media following
her ban on instagram sick Thank You
Brent cope
that he wrote that bell returns to
social media
she was arrested everybody's on board
with the insanity I tried to reach out
to him I was like what's going on where
are you she didn't respond uh-huh she's
very cryptic but I feel like the timing
of that had to have been yeah and yeah
boss to our podcast yeah yeah she's
clearly a fan but okay but watch I'm
glad first of all cuz that people
someone made a really good comment to
like when somebody goes disappearing on
the internet for that long it's usually
a bad thing
so she's at least confirmed to us that
she's fine yeah that she's you know
takes a break from naming yeah she's
taking a break from work for whatever
reason but then again I mean she's got
all this attention again and and there's
no new news as Zack will attest another
breakup yeah well your dessert yeah I
don't want to like I don't want to know
what you you got a new girl yeah what so
I mean does she know about bail just
that the subscription we got yeah that
you know I smelled her Spey tonight say
what we all did so that's not weird
yeah but there's no there's no butcher
new girlfriend be upset if she knew that
you watched Bella delphine porn I don't
owe you no good
oh you don't watch but if you did I
don't okay well let's not even that's
not even entertain the hypothetical
right um at any rate she's fantastic
I'm glad that her hamster is okay I'm
glad that she's okay frankly I was a
little concerned I mean she's got all
that like true detective [ __ ] in her how
you know what I mean she's playing with
octopuses and doesn't for two months I'm
like oh this girl's and some she's like
in someone's basement and like like a
pink dollhouse room but I'm she's okay
so hey you know that's great was that
yeah the true detective other one in the
basement and it was all like pain
everything was pink and it was locked in
the basement some poor little girl hey
give me the creeps just thinking about
it but hey it's the age some people say
this is the best show I mean some people
are more people are saying more more
people people are saying on the street
the podcast is the best show really you
just walk around and you hear people
I've been told that just chitchat just
over here and I hear I hear whispers and
I hear chatter isn't a hipster coffee
shop the other day and I just overheard
people saying h3 podcast it's the best
show you see true story
well are you kidding no well then people
do say that on the street they come and
they say hi Ethan I'm a big fan of show
it's the best show it's my favorite show
and did they say to me I don't know why
you don't have even more views they said
to me cuz it's so good they say I'm like
well if you say so but but and short
bells fine so those good news god Trish
Trisha [ __ ] I'm so tired
it's a hour and a half we should talk
about Trisha she's so crazy girls
[ __ ] insane Trisha Trisha what's your
last name Peters Vedas oh she came at me
on Twitter first of all we need to start
here I made a joke about China because I
was all worked up about China and I said
excuse my bluntness but the Chinese
government can suck my tiny Jewish dick
as she was quipped knew it was tiny
that's what I said I just said that
dum-dum you confirmed her suspicious
suspicion yeah but I'm self-deprecating
huh
okay new was tiny well she should know
since she's uh apparently she came out
recently as a trans a male so I guess
she was know something about small penis
size although I bet you Trish's got in a
large [ __ ] that's bigger than my [ __ ]
she's got one of those weird girl right
I've got like an engorged lid it's like
the size of a [ __ ] like she's
probably got gnarliest genitals do you
know what I'm saying
exactly mark no we can talk about this
I'm just saying she knew it was tiny
yeah well [ __ ] I knew you had a giant
[ __ ] look like the size yep bigger than
my penis that's right you've got a 10
inch clip you are trans male anyway
let's continue on she goes she goes uh
she came out as trans she what the [ __ ]
and then look at this shot she's what
are we doing here Danna did Dan you left
a really funny note I'll read before we
talk about drew he goes she'll wait did
she remove her original because this is
the apology for the original know the
original still up or at least as it it
was up as of Wednesday I thought she
took it down but she's got like multiple
channels I didn't know yeah that's the
first sign of like and Sandy when you
have like don't you have like for like
yeah like soon ice has like shoenice a
Samar
shoenice oatmeal eating a shoe nice
eating deodorant look he's got like yeah
I do have four channels though so I
should
not criminate myself so oh wow got a lot
of views so joke's on us I guess I am
I'm transgender female to male 3 million
views nice nice ratio like dude you know
it's good when she's on her kitchen
floor
who the [ __ ] decides to make videos on
the kitchen floor like I have a shot of
her ice tray bro is she sitting on the
floor that's what I want to know yes
sound like a little snow like a little
she's on the floor of her kitchen yeah
how could that be the optimal place to
shoot a YouTube video
did you know what I mean anyway she may
she pulls it off so brave she can set
back a movement she lets in a moment
where she's like I guess she doesn't do
any cuts I forget what it's like the cut
cuz I did some podcast like I mean this
is all the kind of [ __ ] but the
transgender community so like I should
be for it stopping me was like I always
thought oh my gosh am i trans and I know
like I know I had to make trolden stuff
in the past and so know what people
think there's like a trolling video I've
known like I've like come out as like
gay before I proposed bisexual before
mmm and that's kind of why I have issues
in general which is terms in general and
labels and general like male/female gay
straight but because
you ever you replaced Soulcalibur
there's that one wild-ass Soul Calibur
bondage dude maybe I shouldn't do this
on this one bondage fighter you gonna
know them so it to give people some
Bulldog Bulldog idea a little
explanation of the video cuz I did watch
it and this is why you watched it will
then go ahead anymore she just kind of
describes like a lot of people she says
I don't know some days I don't wear
makeup and I just were comfy clothes
Tran I mean she's trans I really relate
to man and I like to hang out with men
more than women mm-hmm
and so therefore she thinks she's a guy
well people have always thought you were
trans healer so trance Cal Trans
skeleton so maybe that explains cuz you
were saying you you identify out for
what which what she was saying
yeah I do but and I don't think it's
that crazy and I think that's like that
describes a lot of you think you just
call that like a tomboy but you're not
even a tomboy you're just not girly just
not that girly I guess yeah yeah well
that the pair the trans no she's what
that means actually is you're a
female-to-male trans that's so crazy got
her a great clicks though
anyway shoot so she caught a lot of [ __ ]
for it and then she issued an apology
video for her it's like a trilogy like
she saw this look at that shot Bay bad
that doesn't look trans to me that looks
like a female this shot that's like
she's not on the bathroom anymore or the
kitchen is that a top or a bra or like
what is that dude that's a lot of
cleavage bro like it's like a cleavage
cam like if you it it's like half of the
shot or even more is just cleavage do
you know what I'm saying yeah yeah it's
pretty obvious anyway when she made that
first one she's like
okay so I'm gonna post this one I'm
opposed to apology in two days she's
finding out her whole week of posting
videos I don't really know if she was
planning all this because she's crying
the whole time I don't think she's
enjoying it overwhelmed by the well dude
she's my roller coasters issued more
apology videos than anyone I've ever
seen on YouTube and she's crying in
every video though like let let me look
at her oh this is her just pull up her
channel in the video yeah exactly it's
honestly hilarious it's just all the
thumbnails
look ela they're all she's crying and
everything oh yeah her video today was
borderline personality disorder
crying I'm questioning crying apology
crying here I'm not doing well at all
crying don't put a bra on me okay but
don't okay
I won't I'll never do that oh she I was
gonna be like wow she was she I was a
laborer works on the bottom riot yeah
well there's - look how wide I don't
know if I'm really happy
crying why fat shaming works oh [ __ ]
that's a hot take crying wasn't that
your take that she's not matter oh yeah
the ground virus reality right um that
is a very graphic thumbnail frankly
speaking but she's probably you can't
see her face when she is probably crying
let's get off screen
I don't want see that here she is eating
a bucket of chicken here she is eating
Popeyes well we do that to everything
I'm bouncing well yeah I didn't say
there's anything wrong with that I just
said I want to save these for later to
watch everything wrong with the vlog
squad part to fighting back tears Oh
hear that yeah she got the crying emoji
in the damn thumbnails the whole
internet is laughing at me because of
this viral video these thumbnails
actually are fantastic I was just a
titties right there showing you the
goods imagine nothing
that's incredible here she is kicking
back some pasta
she's a MOOC banger did you know that
yellow
no she doesn't MOOC Bank she's almost
like the female shoenice if you think
about it like like if she she's like one
deodorant bar away from being shoenice
like if she just lost one deodorant bars
worth of brain cells she would be
shoenice you know yeah there's a lot of
fun Korean fried cheese for the first
time well that's exciting of I'll save
that for later and ready to date again
cry anyway you get the idea I mean I
could look at these thumbnails forever
frankly well it seems like there was
less drama yeah she's having a hard time
yeah or at least the crying is working
for her because look at the view good
apology I'm questioning personality
disorders hot everyone's talking about
that
her beef with me did really well for her
where was that one do we miss that
where's the one where she called you
like a she said that you need to be on
one of the other channels like I said
she's she's got a few because this was a
lot of subs this was like a dim I think
this one has no nose but she has another
one that's just her name that also has
quite a few and there was some [ __ ] on
there too it seemed like it was all the
same kind of content she's like what the
difference is she's like no no this one
I shoot on the bathroom over my kitchen
floor my living room yeah this one's
less popular but equally active here she
is eating in and out well that's
fantastic behind the scenes of the
eating the Korean fried cheese in my car
excellent
alright yeah Allah zone the main show
here folks
now she's I want to hear the apology
don't you and just I'm overwhelmed by
the amount of backlash I obviously I put
out that video and in no way did I think
I would get so much backlash and he and
I don't really think whenever you watch
this time this is honestly 90 minutes
cuz I just I never on the Chinese
government
you can I control everything
Dannan what why is this truck why do you
not watch this it's not are you not
taking this seriously are you not taking
her pains here not interesting who cares
about her I hate that we're feeding the
troll' right now honestly why we feeding
the troll' because it's still fun
everybody's having fun making fun of
Trish she's like shoenice but didn't eat
deodorant bars but she'll be like she'll
be she'll be dumb like she'll she'll
she's like 10 15 20 IQ points away from
being sure nice I swear to god there's
something about glue ei too much glue or
something
where's your comment you said Oh Dan
said genuinely why are we having this
dumbass troll on the show he said just
for you he says can we invite an actual
trans youtuber like contract points
instead if it sucks yeah we can have
conscience points gone down assuming she
wants to come on but maybe maybe we'll
shoot for that what do you mean a real
trans person though she's she has a
[ __ ] dude she has a five-inch clip
bro Wow well yeah what can I do it's a
real thing I've seen it before it's I've
never seen that before where Bob you
know wherever you see stuff like that
I mean Zach knows what I'm talking about
he's backing me up right Zach yeah yeah
Trisha I'm gonna read your notes Tim
because I don't know you to personality
Trisha Paytas set off a series of
disapproving social media reactions
Monday after claiming to be trans
despite identifying 1,000% with her
birth gender checkmate I mean that
that's a direct quote from her that's
not editorializing still checkmate the
video is about 15 minutes long begins
with Paytas warning that people might
think I'm trying to be offensive or
setback the movement she appears to
identify as transgender a part-time
basis saying identify as a boy a lot of
the times and I penetrate other people
with a giant engorged [ __ ] that's like
bad sometimes people on the train think
that I have an erection but it's just
blank gorgeous glad is so vulgar I don't
like saying it but I don't know how else
to describe it she has created an
ongoing series of controversial and
attention-grabbing videos she previously
appeared a video while wearing underwear
on her head claiming to identify as a
person what does that mean I mean not to
identify as a person to wear comment she
also is claimed to identify as a chicken
nugget I remember several I mean I'm
just reading what's here over several
since deleted videos she allegedly
appeared in yellow face well for
portraying a Japanese chicken nugget
those are two separate
statements okay the chicken nugget in
the Shia's claims to identifies a
chicken nugget she appeared in a video
and yellow clanks ear and yellow face
that's what I want I'll try and find it
thank you a conversation that's how this
really ship works I asked for yellow
face Patricia and you make it happen why
the hesitancy you don't want to see the
chicken nugget face it's it's not
something else why are you complaining
because he wrote it in the same bullet
point she's evolved from an article
editorial she's appearing in yellow face
as a Japanese started the implication
that she's racist right the racist
moment yes honestly well go ahead and
find that
oh wait I'm looking for it I'm not
seeing it okay well we'll work on that
next week and then finally we're nearing
the end of our episode obviously I mean
again who's already I think it was over
before it started
yeah that's hoping he has some good
content for us for next week because
this is a low-quality bro Tiger belly
[Laughter]
okay kids
no squeak we're gonna watch a movie yep
okay finally you guys recall how I was
talking about three beats slide was
coming at us they were trying to three
beats slide their way did anything
happen well any updates no it takes ten
days to get the video back and then oh
it has to go by in good luck at the
point like then thank you bye good luck
I do appreciate and Godspeed and don't
forget the belt Delphine spit huh I got
a piece so bad and in short I do want to
oh my god I like forgot that Tricia was
on the screen and I was like oh god what
is that when I looked at a TV like oh my
god
anyway let's get her out of here so if
you go to this is dedicated to the three
beats slide okay I direct all of you to
go to copyright dot-gov slash fair use
okay these are all published cases of
fair use and the American law lexicon
these are case studies going all the way
back to the beginning of time you're
going all the way back to 1841 then 1950
that's strange
that's a big gap
this is everything okay
not a lot guess who is on this list 2017
is the year one poor son of a gun step
to me this like I haven't done a song
yeah
its historical my name is Matt Hussein
Zod and I sued the man I don't know and
I'm the poor bastard that shot him not
I'm Chyna Hussein Sodom Saudis I decline
mother Fricker's 2017 fair use found you
see this copyright dot gone mother Fred
you want a step to me dude I'm on this
list do you understand that I'm an
activist I'm a fighter I'm a winner I
know what I'm doing you dare take down
my video and I'm took on Hussein's Atta
the great parkour boss
you dare challenge me
Ethan climb climb Ethan and he look line
we were both defendants when I beat
I beat him in the courtroom and now I'm
challenging you officially Hussein
sought it on the our core course not
office oh are you going after him was we
going after three slide right I'm
getting carried away
you're fine Matt we're all good that's
what I earned the bridge what if he
watches our show I don't think so
you think he's moved on yeah I think so
too which is good is for the best
I think that was I think that was
traumatic for all of us mm-hmm that
being said he did he was the catalyst
for all of it but I think it was
stressful for him as well yeah but at
any rate who's a three-beat slide I'm
just saying I'm a published I came up
with a question
isn't this amazing you what is this show
is this watchable this podcast yes
that's your question
it's a podcast I don't know with people
- yeah yes it's what I mean I don't know
apparently I'm being apparently it is
watchable people watch it I don't know
about this specific episode let's leave
a comment just tell us did you watch
this part when we talked about when Ella
asked another question what's the the
key word the key word leave in the
comment
the key word is the key word of this
episode is
free oh yeah Zach thank you
the keyword of this episode is five inch
and gorged mega Clint Zach why didn't
you say it you wrote it he said Clint I
didn't know how you were gonna feel
about it you didn't say it because it's
still vulgar to say yeah this is a weird
episode I agree is this yeah I also have
the same I share the game same concerns
you did I'm tired
we didn't start till three we're doing
all kinds of [ __ ] this morning I would
didn't have enough time to prepare that
I usually do because we'd we're at
Disneyland all yesterday I was screaming
all day
my voice is [ __ ] up it's Friday there
was a fire burning down half the city
yeah it's a little tough okay thought
your question but you guys won't smear
the judge tell us what you think this
episode maybe they like it cuz it's off
the cuff that's wild and just so down to
earth it James breaking all the rules
yes it's off their realm it's off the
rails exactly people like when you're
off the rails because uh if you just
don't know what's gonna happen next
now the true test is dead LOL can we do
dead air like that's the cheetah like
sometimes when i'm listening to a show
and for whatever reason there's like a
long stretch of dead air and you go to
my phone perception like how much dead
air can we hold do you want to test it
okay at this point why not okay all
right here we go
dead air in three two one
we didn't make a very long laughing
count yeah no I mean they Bruin did that
air when we laughed but we did like 20
seconds or something
[Music]
I'm done by the way we can end it
I just wishing Zach well heard Zach Ian
well
he's gone yeah starting the music Oh
what no Riku thank you back though
[Music]
literally that's what he was doing was
that engage everybody or we only do so
next week is that to say to the crowd I
want to know what do you have top 20
move it along to me yeah I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm just texting something
important that's it that's it
then just apologize then for what
exactly for a bomb as Megan Joe we ready
at the end so I mean there's no there's
no bit digital value to this part of the
show unless you actually want to watch
this train wreck
otherwise you could have stopped
watching when the show went over do you
know what I'm saying like there's no
harmony Bert yeah you could bail early
Bert tweeted he said yo h3 and ela great
interview with Casey
vlogging nearly caused a divorce oh
thank you very all say oh thank thank
these songs over thanks everybody for
watching
appreciate you sorry
[Music]
you
[Music]